Let's look into this a bit further.
I want to arrange my 10 sticks
of gum with 1 pack per column.
So if I bought 2 packs of
gum with 5 sticks each,
I would have 2 columns and
each column will have 5 sticks of gum.
So I can just rearrange that a little
bit, and it'll look like this.
I now have 2 columns of gum,
1 column for
each pack and 5 rows of gum,
so 5 pieces in each pack.
To find the total number
of sticks of gum,
I can multiply the number of
packs of gum, which is 2,
by the number of sticks per pack,
which is 5, and that gives 10.
So I have 10 sticks of gum.
But if I had instead bought 5
packs of gum with 2 sticks each,
I would have 5 columns and
each column would have 2 sticks of gum.
That would look like this.
See, 5 columns, 1 for each pack,
and 2 rows, 1 for each piece.
I still have 10 pieces of gum.
They're just arranged differently.
These two arrangements are equivalent.
We have just reversed the rows and
the columns.
Switching the order of the rows and
the columns does not change the results.
This is the main characteristic
of the commutative property.
The commutative property states that
changing the order of the terms does
not change the outcome of the operation.
So which operations follow
the commutative property?
Addition, subtraction,
multiplication, division.
Please select all that apply.